let's go next to I I don't know how to
say this is it sake from California am I
pronouncing that even approximately
correctly
no that's all right what's the right
pronunciation
um I go well my name is it's a shorter
or nickname I go by it's like sign like
the song The Tool you use and then Chi
as in Tai Chi or something
Sachi Kazi is that right
yeah so it's not it's my answers about
that do you know how to pronounce it I
guess let's start there
um I want to go wait like salt and
cheese because you know oh what like the
tools song and
she hasn't Tai Chi or something all
right well what's on your mind today
um well first I want to say um
conversation on your child thank you
sometimes for me to say that now and um
oh
boy sorry yesterday so your con your
connection is going almost like uh like
Lo-Fi uh so what did you have a question
just because I want to make sure I get
to it before we potentially get
disconnected yeah um okay I have another
question yes um do you think that the
Republicans
um if they were to take over the house
they didn't want to make
America the us or the United States kind
of like a dictatorship country like
like uh
most of the country uh but
North Korea in a way no they would not
be able to install a dictator so as
horrible as it will be if Republicans
take over the house and or Senate they
will obstruct Joe Biden they will say
horrible things they will continue to
encourage political violence they're
going to do all of those things but they
will not at least in the next two years
turn the us into a dictatorship
my team because like I remember when
Trump was still president at the time it
felt like it was going to be a
leadership right to me anyway no no no I
mean listen if you have the president
the house and the Senate then it's a
little bit different
I say okay
Sachi Kazi I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly from California I really
appreciate the call
ing it's an honor to talk with you I'll
make I'm a big fan thank you so much uh
very much appreciate it let's take a
very quick break don't hang up don't
hang up unless you're just mad at me but
please stay on the line because we're
going right back to the phones in a
moment the David packman shows longest
running sponsor is blinkist the app that
takes thousands of non-fiction books
boils each of them down into an
explainer you can read or listen to in
15 minutes blinkist also condenses
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers I've been using
blinkist for years to supplement the
books I read I love reading I I read all
the time but there's even more books I
don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below